faire
[Musique]
le restaurant
c'est comme on l'appelle comme un laboratoire
comme l'endroit où on vient on
teste et on essaie et tout le temps on travaille euh on
ouvre genre quatre jours et on prend deux
jours juste pour la préparation pour
mieux comprendre tout quoi  nous le faisons, nous le testons
de temps en temps, euh pour obtenir un reçu, nous pouvons prendre
environ trois mois et encore une fois, nous l'
essayons, essayons, jusqu'au moment où nous disons, ok, c'est
ce que nous voulons et nous pouvons le partager
avec nos invités.
[Musique]
quelque chose de différent  ce qui se passe maintenant en
Afrique et les gens s'intéressent
à en savoir plus sur la cuisine africaine
parce que quand vous parlez de
cuisine africaine, allez sur Google, parfois vous voyez
juste du riz
ou comme la mafia ou ou comme le yasa mais
euh
c'est plus que ça, c'est plus que ça c'est  pourquoi je pense que
beaucoup de gens sont de plus en plus intéressés
à en savoir plus sur la cuisine africaine
[Musique]
faire